hi there we're at lawn fest and uh i'm
with mark pendleton
voila of coffee break spanish french
italian how many languages spanish
french italian german and madrid okay
one of the advantages and we're going to
talk a bit about lawn fest we have the
long fest logo behind us one of the
exciting things here is not only to meet
keen language learners and polyglots but
also to meet people who like us are
providing services and features and
learning tools for language learners so
mark what i would like to do first of
all is ask you about sort of your
impressions of this meeting and and and
what it gives you and what you think it
gives other people and then we'll get
into coffee break fantastic all right so
tell me what has been your impression of
this conference it's been fantastic to
to be with like-minded people i i've
always considered myself a little bit of
a of a language geek
and certainly growing up i think i was
probably the only language geek in my
school and so on but suddenly finding
myself um with people
uh with whom i can compare
my love for certain textbooks over
others the font that is used in certain
textbooks and everything like that had a
really really granular level um has been
has been really good fun i think
everyone who is here is is so open to
all languages and to to sharing a love
of languages into practicing
absolutely which languages do you speak
uh i've heard your excellent french and
italian i think um i always kind of
say that it depends on your definition
of speak i'm fairly confident in in
french spanish italian uh to a lesser
extent in portuguese german norwegian
and
a couple of others oh okay
now
tell us a little bit about coffee break
languages and how you got into it okay
coffee break languages was born in 2006
and basically what we it was born out of
uh uh
working with with adult learners and
adult learners very often telling me uh
that they didn't have time to to learn a
language and for me uh i wanted to take
that question and turn it around and say
well what what can i do to help people
learn a language in the time that they
do have because i think we all we all
have time in our lives that we're
perhaps doing other things that we could
be learning the language while we're
doing those other things right i'm
thinking of things like um in the car or
at the gym absolutely walking the dog or
doing the dishes or whatever whatever
happens to be the thing and i'm not
saying you you use every moment of your
your life your spare time your down time
to learn a language but i think there
are times that we could use for language
learning that we we perhaps waste
and so back in 2006 we started
developing coffee break spanish as a as
a resource that would allow people to
use those 20-minute sessions that they
they may have right constructively for
for learning a language and since then
we've developed uh courses from an a1
level up to almost c1 right in our in
french and spanish and with italian and
german we've got two levels and uh we
just introduced mandarin this year oh
okay
you know i should say that when i go to
learn language typically i use a variety
of resources
and i end up liking some better than
others
for example for my recent efforts at
hebrew and greek i bought living
language which i have to confess that i
found not very good at all
but
we do use different resources and there
are people who come to link and they say
there's no explanation and i don't
understand the grammar and so on and so
on and so i think there is definitely
not only with
coffee break languages but with the
other services that are out there
there's always an element of of a sort
of complementary relationship and so i
think in that sense uh people who come
to link you know i could see people
spending some time with with a resource
like yours or a pimpler or a michelle
thomas and i i think
to the extent that i'm you know familiar
with your product there's more
explanation there's more english it's an
easing into you're sitting in the car
it's not like solid target language and
you don't know what they're talking
about so to that extent it's kind of an
easing into say link which is pure
target language yeah yeah i think i
firmly believe there is there is space
for everyone in the
in the business right um and i think any
anyone using only one resource for
learning a language is crazy because
you do need those different resources
right i mean again i'm all about the
concept of coffee break learning and
being able to to do something for 20
minutes but you know equally you could
spend
an hour doing lessons or indeed if
you've only got the five minutes while
you're waiting for the bus right then
you would need something else to get
your kind of espresso break right
and in that situation yeah whether it's
link whether it's getting an app or
something like that that's filling that
down time with an opportunity to to
practice what you've learned to
consolidate what you've learned in a
different way and getting different
input and and then practicing that with
with uh with the output that you're
using absolutely and i and i think too
that that variety i think you know i
have mentioned in my videos this the
german
neuroscientist who said that the brain
requires
novelty and repetition
and i think variety introduces that's
kind of a way to get the same content
from different sources and different
methods so you don't end up feeling
frustrated that you know you're always
doing the same thing so um yeah i think
you know we're going to see whether
there aren't some ways that
there we can introduce some
complimentary anyway yeah thank you for
the interview
and i think it's a real treat for
because a lot of my listeners are not
native speakers of english and i think
it's the first time
it's the first time we've had some good
scottish english here so if there's any
questions or people who require a
transcript
please let me know i'd be delighted to
relate whatever you need
thank you for listening
[Music]
you